en este vídeo vamos a seguir trabajando
con la fórmula del error cuadrado de la
recta de la recta de regresión para
hacer más claros y vamos a ver que si
tenemos esta expresión que es a la que
llegamos desarrollando los cuadrados de
binomio hasta el término enésimo vamos a
ver lo siguiente
supongamos supongamos que tenemos esto
que queremos averiguar tenemos una serie
de puntos si queremos averiguar el
promedio de todos los i es decir de
todos los cuadrados
mejor dicho tenemos el primero al
cuadrado el segundo al cuadrado y así
sucesivamente hasta llegar al enésimo al
cuadrado para buscar el promedio de esto
tendríamos que dividirlo por la cantidad
de números que estamos sumando es decir
n y esto nos va a dar entonces el
promedio o la media de todos los
cuadrados ahora si nosotros
multiplicamos por n ambos miembros
vamos a ver que está n se simplifica con
esta otra n y que nos queda que y al
cuadrado subo uno más y sub dos al
cuadrado más
y sub n al cuadrado es igual al promedio
de todas las cuadrados por n y fíjense
que esta expresión esta expresión está
atacada es igual a esta expresión que
tenemos acá que es la sumatoria de todos
los n iv que tenemos por lo tanto a esta
expresión podemos llamarla
tranquilamente
vamos a dejarlo así
n x y al cuadrado barra o todos los
promedios de todos los y al cuadrado
lo mismo que ocurrir por ejemplo si en
vez de querer averiguar el promedio de
todos los y al cuadrado queremos
averiguar el promedio de todos los y por
x nuevamente dada una serie de puntos
nosotros queremos ver qué sucede o cuál
es el promedio de multiplicar a todos
los y ya todos los x de cada punto
esto nos queda x 2 x y dos más al
término enésimo que sería x n por n todo
esto claro está dividido por n que es la
cantidad de puntos que tenemos esto
entonces es igual a la media de todos
los x
nuevamente sí
multiplicamos por n ambos términos ambos
miembros perdón
vamos a poder simplificar esta n con
esta n y nos quedaría
que x sub 11 y sub 1 + x sub 22
mas x su n y sub n es igual al promedio
de todos los x por y por n y este que
está ahí es igual a éste
a esta expresión que tenemos acá por lo
tanto podemos llamar esta expresión como
n x
x y barro y con el mismo criterio vamos
a poder realizar exactamente lo mismo
con cada una de estas expresiones
así esta expresión se va a llamar n por
ibarra esta n por todo el promedio de
los x cuadrados y esta última n por el
promedio de todas las x
de esta forma si bajamos acá podemos rex
reescribir al error cuadrado de la recta
de la siguiente manera
podemos escribirlo entonces como
n por el promedio de los y cuadrados
menos 2 m por n por el promedio de los x
por y menos 2 b por n por ibarra
más en el cuadrado por n vamos a más
separado en el cuadrado por n por x
cuadrado o el promedio de todos los x al
cuadrado si boca abajo más 2 m b por n
por el promedio de todos los x más n
veces veía al cuadrado y está ahora sí
es una forma mucho más simplificada
mucho más sencilla
para poder obtener lo que nosotros
buscamos que lo que nosotros queremos es
minimizar esta expresión lo que queremos
hacer entonces es encontrar m&b que
minimicen esta fórmula esta ecuación
esta expresión ahora miremos la fórmula
fíjense que nuestras incógnitas en este
caso no son los y ni las n sino que son
2 b
clase m
por lo tanto tenemos una multiplicación
de incógnitas y tenemos las incógnitas
también en segundo grado por lo tanto
podemos mirar a esto como una ecuación
como una ecuación cuadrática si no me
equivoco y lo digo bien como una
ecuación cuadrática es decir como un
gráfico en tres dimensiones supongamos
que bajemos esto
supongamos
que tenemos
los ejes
los ejes del plano es decir de la
incógnita m y de la incógnita y que el
eje vertical
va a ser el que viene dado por el error
cuadrado de la recta
quiero que se note que esto esto vamos a
verlo de esta forma esto me delimita
los 8 oct antes que vamos a tener en el
espacio cuando trabajamos en el plan no
tenemos cuadrantes y en este caso que
estamos trabajando en el espacio tenemos
oct antes tenemos 8 oct antes por lo
tanto para cada valor que nosotros
tengamos de m y debe vamos a obtener
otro valor de la ecuación cuadrada del
error cuadrado de la recta es decir que
vamos a ir obteniendo puntos en el
espacio en cada uno de los obstantes así
hasta determinar un gráfico que es el
siguiente
un gráfico que es algo así que es como
una
como una copa sin embargo esto esto
sigue hacia arriba
y esto sigue hacia arriba
y queda definido algo así como esta
especie de copa por así decirlo
tridimensional es muy difícil hacer un
gráfico tridimensional en un plano pero
con ayuda de la imaginación de ustedes
vamos a poder llegar a buen puerto
entonces queda determinada esta especie
de copa otra forma de verla es como si
tuviésemos una parábola
que la hacemos girar sobre un eje
hacemos girar entonces sobre un mismo
eje y la misma parábola es la genera
triz de esta función que nos queda
gráfica da acá una una palabra clave
infinita verdad que va hasta el infinito
con sus ramas por lo tanto se va a
extender también esto hasta el infinito
pero no me quiero meter mucho en estos
temas sino que quiero que comprendan que
lo que tenemos que hacer es minimizar
esta esta gráfica optimizar esta función
en esta superficie y minimizar la clave
está para eso vamos a tener que entonces
que derivar esta expresión de acá
todo lo que viene acompañado por eso
vamos a tener entonces que optimizar
minimizar más específicamente y buscar
los planos para los cuales la pendiente
los planos tangentes a esta a este
gráfico con una pendiente igual a cero
es decir que vamos a tener que buscar
las derivadas parciales
derivadas
parciales
e igualar las a 0 para así poder
conseguir lo que tanto estamos buscando
hace tantos vídeos